this is Startalk welcome to Startalk
Allstars I'm Jan 11 and I'm your
all-star host today I'm an
astrophysicist and author but nowhere
near as interesting as my co-host the
incredibly talented Matt kirshen Matt
welcome to New York hey thank you for
welcoming both here and to the show and
for pointing out that I'm more
interesting than enough surfaces and
that's right and we're going to hold you
to that for the rest of you her interest
also in the studio we have special guest
Shepard Dolman who has a long list of
accomplishments including getting
through graduate school at MIT same year
as me and together getting me through
general relativity Shep is an
astrophysicist at the
harvard-smithsonian Center for
Astrophysics and the director of the
event horizon telescope project event
horizon telescope is a fantastic project
not yet complete still under development
it is a telescope essentially the size
of the entire Earth that is going to try
to take the first real picture of a
black hole very exciting stuff so this
is what we're going to talk about today
good day's work if we can pull it off
it's a good day's work so we're going to
be talking about black holes how we
observe them so far why we think they're
real and what it would mean to take a
real picture of them for the first time
so Shep thanks so much for coming making
the trip from MIT it's pretty hard
thanks for having me it's a pleasure
today we're going to delve into one of
the weirdest and sort of most exciting
topics in astrophysics everyone loves to
talk about black holes and in
particularly how we observe them but
first let's just start with you know
what is a black hole Shep
so everybody yeah pretty strange
I get it I see how things are someone's
already playing favorites I didn't go to
school with you I think you didn't go
back to 20 years you just go to chef to
immediately ask about a black hole yeah
you didn't graduate from MIT what have
you written that look what they have a
beaver on them pretty nice yeah the
beaver ring is the MIT class ring
industrious and why you're calling yes I
know
all right face says it all oh because
the building thing is all right that
mean I build telescopes we image black
holes that's what we're about you so
black holes so
black holes what are they but I think
well everyone has some idea of what a
black hole is but essentially it's when
gravity is run amok
it's when mass collapses in on itself to
the point where gravitational runaway is
inevitable and nothing can keep matter
from infalling to a singularity to a
point and the interesting and defining
thing about a black hole this is what we
all probably know about is that there's
this membrane called the event horizon
around the black hole and that's the
point outside the singularity where
gravity is so strong that even light
can't escape now then hangs off to the
movie the other way around actually you
know but it's uh it's what most people
think about when they think about the
event horizon the movie and the
spaceship that went into hell and then
came back out haunted so the event
horizon means no events that happen on
the other side of that line will ever be
known to you so it separates causally
right two parts of space okay what
happens in the event horizon I can
advance event horizon so in an actual
membrane it's not an actual membrane
it's just a region of space-time that
demarks where gravity is so strong that
the escape velocity from that mass is
the speed of light
once you pass through it you really
can't get back out again that if you can
actually stick a light pulse right at
the event horizon and racing outwards at
the speed of light it wouldn't go
anywhere it would just sit there it
refrozen it would be yet just hovering
there it's as though almost as though
space times falling in like a waterfall
so what would you see if you were
actually right at that event Horace you
would pass the light pulse and think
it's traveling at the speed of light so
but this is a good question Matt because
you say matter is a dense you know
crushes under its own weight
a big enough star will crush under its
own weight eventually so is there stuff
there like people think of a black hole
this incredibly dense object so when I
cross the event horizon like Matt asked
is there anything there usually there's
nothing there there's a weird active I
call like the ones are in the center of
our galaxy or in other galaxies you just
pass right through the event horizon
like it's not there you can't get back
out again it's one of these strange
things that's why philosophers get very
dreamy when you talk to them about black
holes in a way that they don't when you
talk to them about stars because world
lines can go through the event horizon
and you don't know what happens so well
either
well a world line is where you are
following space and time on your own
trajectory and I go from this point to
that point from point A to point B but
if point B is inside the event horizon
you can't get back out again so you
can't tell your friends where you are or
how you got there you know how Google
Maps plots your spatial path they should
do a spacetime diagram all right so the
world lines your path through space and
through time but sometimes it gets it
wrong and it picks like the wrong
Massachusetts or whatever and then it
says you need to take a boat and then
you need to take a left turn right and
then boat and then you never escape
sorry I got it but the thing about the
GPS units is they do actually have to
correct for relativity to get your
location right on the map so our clocks
run a little bit slower here on earth
than they do say at the satellites and
so they have to correct for that time
difference the fact that our clocks are
running slower they were aging slightly
more slowly in order to locate you
properly on the earth so and that's
that's hugely interesting right because
Einstein developed this theory of
general relativity in 1915 over to 101
years ago and sometimes I imagine going
back and talking to Einstein saying here
professor Einstein you know you're a
hundred years from now and have to put
on the voice you have to put on the
voice oh I don't put on the voice isn't
a sound good right so you go back in
time you say to Einstein you talk to
everyone in the accents they have it
you're going to start a feeding British
to man don't get me started
yeah but you talk to Einstein you would
say a hundred years from now Corrections
that you discovered will enable me with
my phone to take down links from a
constellation of satellites around the
earth and pinpoint my location anywhere
on the earth and of course he'd be very
excited he would say what's a phone
right now because we've our technology
has gone so far beyond what Einstein had
that the first thing he'd be interested
in is or what's a phone and that he
wouldn't he refused to memorize his
phone number because he said why would I
memorize anything I could look up like
why clutter your mind yours praise
Einstein you can get whoever loves yeah
well he also said when I was a student I
was no Einstein so how do we know this
he's illegal Einstein is it does not
make us kind of on a pause that's right
it works in both directions also I don't
know why
phone number so I'm exactly what you
have a phone so actually clearly very
similar wouldn't have had a phone number
maybe so maybe this is one of those
apocryphal stories that I'm propagating
without having properly looked into the
decision here of all that is so black
holes Einstein understood the
mathematical solution but he wasn't sure
that they were real in fact he sort of
thought nature would protect us from
their formation I mean after all I can't
crush this desk very easily it's very
very hard to do I mean it's hard to fold
a piece of paper more than what's the
number 11 times or something like that
it starts to really fight so he believed
quite sensibly that nature would not
allow something to collapse all the way
to a black hole and there were decades
between that time 1916 this guy in the
trench is an infantry soldier on the
Russian front you know is calculating
ballistic trajectories and writing to
Einstein naturally and he wrote down the
first solution for a black hole do you
know when when it got its name the black
hole David his name's people's Gibbons
wheeler I think we were also Princeton
guy yeah it was 67 and I knock I tell
you I know happened
a year chef was warned and he was tired
of saying end state of complete
gravitational collapse apparently so
someone from the audience shouted how
about black hole and the name stuck
that's 50 years right 50 years it took
for people to really start to believe
that black holes were real so why do we
believe they're real now well it was so
well we're I think about it is that for
a long time people didn't think that
anything could be much denser than water
right so if you take our Sun that the
average density of the Sun is not too
much more than water given its volume
like you fill the whole volume of the
Sun with water it would weigh about what
the Sun ways and it wasn't until people
found white dwarves which are very dense
in states of stars like cinders of stars
it'll be the end state of our Sun for
example and neutron stars that people
began to really you know think that
matter could be compressed to extreme
density just to be clear this is
scientists who didn't think things could
be denser than water and not just like
people in the pub
well I don't have theories like I
remember my friend Jordan telling me
when we were eight that the way we could
travel faster than light is I don't know
if you saw the end of Jaws but like the
way that the canister of like exploded
in the shark's mouth was so powerful it
is like that's as big an explosion as
you can get and that'll get us like
faster than the speed of light and it
turns out Jesus wrong Jordan's one of
those people apparently who write me
those you know there are series of
everything yeah those I bet you do both
scientists you're going to look I'm a
search for the name Jordan yeah my crazy
phone we get these letters that say
Einstein got it wrong by a minus sign
and here's why oh yeah although he did
have a minus sign error in some of his
first papers he yeah but not in
relativity he made mistakes he wasn't
really afraid of that I mean it just
stuff is you know it's not written on a
tablet somewhere it takes some trial and
error but sorry what's her more to
Jordan's theory no that was mostly in I
think we should just call it Jordan's
theory basically anything that can
explode a shock is going to be pretty
powerful
well actually it's quite amazing they
really needed to understand the nuclear
physics that goes into the bomb
technology before they were
sophisticated enough and their
understanding of small scale matter
forces to realize that the black hole
would form so so all these guys really
did work on the bomb but on that happy
note and we're switching to cosmic
queries Matt what do you got whoa okay
so on that note here's a question from a
victor certain back on Facebook who says
a hope from Stockholm Sweden as well is
it possible to kill or destroy a black
hole alive a black hole hunt you really
like that like woods putting a
compressed air canister in the black
hole's mouth and then shooting it from
the boat a shark could easily write like
how Thor would be to eat a black hole
yes it depends on what you mean by
destroys well black holes will evaporate
by themselves it just left to their own
devices right and that's because of
something called Hawking radiation so
the boundary of the black hole is event
horizon is a turbulent place and you can
get particle and tear production right
and one particle will go into the black
hole and one will go out of the black
hole from a distance it looks like the
black hole is giving off particles
slowly evaporating over billions of
years a stellar-mass black hole can just
vanish
alright so that's one way to get rid of
a black hole just leave
loan weighing for a very long time
ignoring a long time before right now
the light left over from the Big Bang is
hotter than all the Astrophysical black
holes we we think we know of so that the
black holes right now are absorbing the
light right from the Big Bang they're
not emitting it yet in a long time
though everything will fall into black
holes and then all those black holes
will evaporate feels like a long like if
this black hole is currently terrorizing
a seaside town like this is not the
approach that you want yeah that would
not be a good ya protective mother
measure yes that wouldn't work but also
a shark's eyes black hole would be a
short massed black hole would be really
tiny can you make that can you have a
black hole that's not sighs oh sure so
if you had a black hole that was the
mass of an asteroid for example let's
say a hundred trillion kilograms it's a
good sized asteroid it would be smaller
than an atom
so wouldn't terrorize the town it would
just drop right to the center of the
earth because there'd be no support for
it well you know we don't actually know
how to force an asteroid to become a
black hole but there was a direct
pressure you draw more more but in the
Large Hadron Collider people were afraid
that by smashing particles together one
of the byproducts was going to be
subatomic sized black holes and so
people did try to tank an injunction
against turning on the Large Hadron
Collider now I remember that being a
thing did any mini like micro black
holes actually get created and if so
what happens awesome no like it was a
hairy thank god okay notice one were to
happen it would actually do bad things
like you even if it is it wouldn't
actually so businesses just are never
willing to say never they're only
willing to say it's very very improbably
right so the argument was black holes
could be made depending on whether there
were extra spatial dimensions and what
gravity is really like at higher
energies but if they were made they
actually evaporate through the process
Shep's describing much faster than big
black holes the smaller the black hole
the faster they evaporate so the idea
was they would just be gone in a flash
it would be like an abrasion or Tyler
different brightly yeah at least that's
the theory the only thing that magic so
the other thing that that people should
feel safe about is that nature has
already done this experiment for us
so people worry about CERN and the Large
Hadron Collider slamming particles
together to make a little black hole but
cosmic rays hit the earth all the time
and they're hugely high-energy their
higher energy you can make in the LHC so
they're slamming into the earth all the
time and they haven't made a black hole
yet to devour the earth maybe they made
a black hole but a black holes have
these tiny little mouths right they're
like huge animals but with tiny little
mouths right so it's very difficult for
them to eat what you're using everything
in shopping and I really appreciated oh
it's a hummingbird of the exotic object
world so do we have some more cosmic
queries yeah so again and I think this
question might turn out to be slightly
off in terms of the way it's phrased but
hunts 105 on Instagram I don't know how
you asked a question on Instagram I
don't know where this is just done by
posing for a picture conveys this quite
about holding up a cardboard yeah right
oh maybe the hunter from the United
States says how close with a black hole
have to be in order to see it with the
unaided eye
so our hmm you'd have to see the shadow
cast because that's all there is to see
so one of the mysteries of black hole
that maybe we'll get to this later but
this is the perfect time is that by
definition you can't see them by
definition all the action happens within
the event horizon once things fall
through even light you can't see it so
why are black holes actually some of the
brightest things we see in the sky
that's because all the gas and dust
that's being attracted to the black hole
is trying to fit into this impossibly
small volume and just as when you rub
your hands together they get hot the
friction of all that gas and dust madly
trying to get into this teeny little
volume heats everything up to hundreds
of billions of degrees so what you're
seeing is everything clamoring to get
into the black hole rather than the
actual black hole ourselves yes it's
like you know like the line outside a
nightclub Roger
something's happening inside there and
it's pretty special but all you can see
is like this big exciting line outside
and the bouncer is kind of like the heat
keeping people everybody out right right
but then you think you know right maybe
it's all pipe so what Shep wants to do
is take an actual picture of the shadow
so that's something amazing but to see
the shadow means there has to be
something bright behind it so if the
black hole is just against a dark sky
there is no hope of seeing it even
unaided but if it was
had the Milky Way galaxy shining behind
it you would see a sort of lens image of
the Milky Way and that's how and you
would see the shadow so it's an
interesting question how close would
have to be so a black hole the size of
the Sun is about six kilometers across
so how close would six kilometers have
to be Shep do you think to be able to
see it with my eyes like right here I
would be like within the solar system
like so if you're out if you're if
you're out in the orbit of Pluto for
example and you look back to the Sun it
you can't even see that right right oh
you have to be well within the orbit of
mercury I would imagine to even see this
kind of thing well so Sebastian dubis on
Facebook says where is the closest black
hole and could we send something to
orbit around it well that's a great
question we often joke that the best way
to study a black hole is to send an
undergraduate with a laser pointer
nearest black hole and throw them in
right and then as they go in the laser
of course would be Doppler shifted and
beginning I'm Ehren into that there
right they totally passed the course
okay yeah that's going to look really
good well the nearest one is it's just
like a few tens of light-years away I
think xmax one that's that's one I
thought it was 6,000 light-years away
Oh fact-checkers yes is there a black
hole at the center of the Milky Way
absolutely a black hole further away
than the nearest black hole that's about
25,000 light-years away okay so the
nearest black hole is that also part of
the Milky Way ahead of this okay yeah so
there's a hundred billion stars in the
Milky Way and about a million of them
would I say 100 billion about billion of
them actually will one day become black
holes it doesn't mean that they all are
now so there's a lot of black holes just
speckled around the galaxy a lot we may
talk about this later but the black hole
the center of our galaxy is one of the
only ones that we can hope to resolve
with any kind of astronomical instrument
so the kind of telescope that Janna was
referring to before the event horizon
telescope can just make out the four
million solar mass black hole in the
center of our galaxy this is a perfect
place to break because we're going to
come back to talk about the event
horizon telescope and how it's going to
resolve that shadow and the excitement
of that project so we're going to take a
short break but stick around so we can
talk more with Shep and Matt about event
horizon telescope on Startalk all star
welcome back to Startalk all-stars as we
continue to talk about black holes and
event horizon telescope
I'm your host Janna Levin and I'm very
excited to have my wonderful comedic
co-host Matt kirshen Jenna hey Matt a
long time no see in a while in a few
seconds and our science guest chef
Dolman chef is the leader of the event
horizon telescope project so tell me a
little bit more about event horizon
telescope so the event horizon telescope
is a project dedicated to the notion
that we can see something that we've
always been taught as unseeable right
everybody knows the black hole is
something that absorbs light matter
nothing come out from the event horizon
once it's gone into the event horizon
but because all the gas and dust is
heated up and you get this effective
3-dimensional flash light all around the
black hole illuminating it from all
angles you can see its shadow or the
silhouette that it casts against all
that hot gas so what about interstellar
Jeana how an interstellar they share the
disk around the black hole but you can
kind of see it above and below do you
think that was a pretty accurate
portrayal I think that's very accurate
right so because it turns out that just
like water going down the bathtub drain
everything kind of falls into this
pancake shape that's swirling around the
black hole it makes like a disk like
holes spin the other way around in
Australia that is not true absolutely
hollow toilet do also spin geography now
earlier I was just in Australia I start
echt yeah so it's one of the great
experiments of our time we can get
toilet bowl astronomers spent a lot of
time looking at toilet bowls I never
spend all kinds of time looking but the
point that jenna is talking about is
quite true there is no behind of a black
hole right so that's that came out wrong
to me the anything that's behind the
black hole by definition gets bent up
and around so light rays from the other
side of the black hole get bent up and
around so you have this pancake object
and you're seeing the rear side of it
flipped up yeah I always stole this line
from you Shep you you once said you
can't hide behind a black hole and it's
actually a great description you're
crouching down behind the black hole and
they can see you and then again one step
too close you're in the black hole my
god that's a bad game is good
than that I should have paid attention
in Astrakhan class Rosie reads on
Instagram is asking what is the
telescope made of oh what a great
question so first of all black holes are
extremely small they're the smallest
objects theorized by Einstein's
gravitational theory and so to see them
you need a large telescope the larger
the telescope the smaller the object you
can see on the sky so to do this we take
radio dishes all around the globe and we
synchronize them with atomic clocks we
point them all at the same time it's
kind of incredible when you think about
it they swivel at the same moment look
at the black hole take radio wave data
from the outside of the event horizon of
this black hole and they record it on
hard disk drives
we essentially freeze the light
everywhere around the globe and we bring
them all back to a specialized
supercomputer that compares them all it
operates exactly the same way that an
optical mirror does for an optical
telescope so for an optical telescope
the light rays hit this perfect
paraboloidal shape and they focus it all
to a point for your camera sense all the
light is focused to a point in the event
horizon telescope we replay all of these
recordings that we've made all around
the earth and we adjust the timing of
them to make it seem as though there is
this huge dish the size of the earth and
then we synthesize this focal point and
that's where we make the image so the
whole earth is a telescope well
telescopes around the earth for night so
it makes right it makes this like giant
machine so how big I mean I remember
this comparison if you resolve the
shadow of the black hole from the
supermassive black hole at the center of
our galaxy which is how how big is it
again it weighs about 4 million times
where our Sun does and about how big
across is it well on the sky it measures
about 10 micro arc seconds and the
shadow would be about 50 micro arc
seconds this is the same as trying to
observe your favorite citrus fruit on
the moon oh it is an jello minute route
you know a pomelo anyway I don't
actually have a favorite citrus frigate
it does sandwich and I'm disappoint you
know and I get
be more free in the past because it
comes up a lot some people are always
like you know what is your favorite like
I don't like them all the same and then
half you choose Matt you have to sound
like one of those parents who like you
can't love all of your children the same
like I just don't have a favorite
amongst when you next go to the moon I
want you to put one that you chose on
the surface of the Moon and we will try
to resolve it with a samurai's and
telescope for gags I'm on the show with
someone that doesn't have long
no I heard it's like resolving a quarter
on the moon is that the same almost it
so it would be a citrus fruit on the
moon bigger than a quarter or huh if you
were in New York now yeah your friend
was in Los Angeles holding a quarter
would be equivalent to reading the date
on that quarter that's what you guys are
trying to you are trying to do so much
of being a professional scientist is
coming up with different sized analogies
better only a lot of the job of like a
be like if Pluto were a baseball and
like your hand was Alpha Centauri and
your dad was throwing Pluto from you
seems like there's a lot of that like
that's what we are a nightmare do I feel
that is a real venture in business put
this in terms of swimming pools and
whales and fruit that's how I need
hamsters to have a trail okay but this
black hole which is four million times
the mass of the Sun probably fits in
about three Sun widths is that does that
sound like about right I don't know it's
about PI about the event rise be about a
third the orbit of mercury
oh so that's actually cuz it's four
million times
oh yeah kilometer figure that you gave
word that was quite large yeah it's
quite large but it's twenty-five
twenty-six thousand light years away
exactly so as I said black holes they
toss the stars around like planets you
know the supermassive ones they're
hugely dynamically important but the
largest one that we know that's close to
us is 25,000 light years away so it's
not going to hurt us we're not in any
danger we are falling into it just
really slow very very like much worse
things are going to happen to us in the
next 10 years
well but not to get off-topic doctor
this is a the biggest black hole in our
galaxy it's at the center of our galaxy
and we think that there are black holes
this big in all the galaxies more or
less do we have any aspiration for
observing the shadow of taking a picture
of the shadow of another black hole
supermassive black hole and another
galaxy
yeah so it turns out there's one other
wonderful candidate for doing this so
the number one target for us is the
supermassive black hole in the center of
the Milky Way galaxy a star which is
called Sagittarius a star in the
constellation Sagittarius and the other
one is in the Virgo a galaxy and that
weighs six billion times what our Sun
does today you'll monster it's a huge
monster it's a thousand times more than
a thousand times bigger
yeah it's about one and a half 1,500
times it would be a subtle part of the
Milky Way different galaxies a whole
galaxy and so that so it's the only
reason why we have any hope of resolving
that is because it's so much bigger even
though it's much further away how much
it your way for tional so it's about
1,500 times more massive it was also
about 1,500 times farther away it looks
about the same on the sky so a telescope
with the same magnifying power would see
them both about the same size so you're
basically building a telescope the size
of the earth to take the picture of two
things in charge they are like yeah I
like to say it this way if I were to be
trapped on a desert island with two
targets these would be the two targets
right we have one that is kind of a
rosetta stone if you will or it's an
exemplar of most of the supermassive
black holes in the universe they're
nondescript in smaller galaxies we
wouldn't see them if they were Norway
our black hole it's just not right it's
just it's not bright because it's just
not taking anything down right now it
was almost starvation diet it's kind of
eating with your you know teaspoon and
so it's not it's not that the gas around
it is hot but it's not enough to really
be seen from very very far away whereas
the Virgo a the supermassive black hole
is is much much brighter and that's
driving a jet of relativistic particles
from its North and South Pole
it's literally piercing
entire galaxy now is that because we're
seeing it in the past when it was our
active well well is it not that far away
we're it's about what's it's about 1817
megaparsecs over 17 million years away
really old and now it's not too old
we're probably seeing it as it's eating
as it's driving these jets from its
north and south pole through the galaxy
so in the past was our black hole at the
center of our galaxy bright Oh almost
definitely so there's probably some
alien civilization on the other side of
the universe where the lights taking
billions of years to get there that
syncs that our black holes like a quasar
how do you think that okay it couldn't
be going better it could not be going
better this is the best universe in
which this show is going the best well
if you like Trump it's the best it's
huge and it's the best the what I'll say
very briefly on this is that about 300
light years from the center of the
galaxy they see these wisps of x-ray
light and they think that what causes
that is that 300 years ago there was a
burst of activity in the center of our
galaxy and the shock wave has reached
the clouds that bound that area and it's
fluorescing so speaking of which we're
seeing the black hole 25,000 years ago
as it was then so wasn't there this
excitement for a while that a cloud was
about to be torn apart by the black hole
g2 Nath cloud - and we watched people
watched it for how long were they
watching this gas class yes so there was
a gas a cloud of gas that they felt was
about three times the mass of Earth and
it was falling into the black hole I
knew they knew was falling in because it
began to be tidally stretched so the
front part of the cloud was feeling more
gravity than the rear part of the cloud
and being sure it's like straining out
right right you look like the exciting
bit when you're watching the water drain
under the bus like when it just suddenly
it's the only fun part of that that
watch yeah shake the towel
anybody but in any event people thought
there was going to be fireworks that
we're going to be fireworks and we
haven't seen anything it's been the
biggest dud all right what do you think
happens well does not fall in a lot of
it depends on how you engage the black
holes if the black hole is spinning this
way
and you're coming in counter to that
rotation you could get a lot of
fireworks but if it's spinning in the
same direction as you you just be sucked
along with it yeah and it might take a
long time for the gas that you're
contributing to the black hole to find
its way all the way to the event horizon
where would light up let's be clear if I
were to fall across the supermassive
black hole in the center the galaxies I
would not be torn to shreds I would just
drift across right we're stuck happily
because I am we compared to the size
event horizon Matt what do we got so cal
OS on instagram is saying will this
telescope be studying the effects of
Hawking radiation probably not so lucky
Kyle mm-hmm no Kyle just a great
question context Kyle from a mat here
it's a great question we know that
Hawking radiation is but the event
horizon telescope is going to see this
outline and Hawking radiation is not
likely to affect that outline there are
some cases in which it might there are
some quantum effects that might affect
the shadow size and that's an active
area of debate right now but Hawking
radiation itself is something that
happens over very long periods of time
and so we probably wouldn't see that
dynamically affect the shadow now I
should point out that we are getting
cosmic queries from our audience through
social media so next time tune in and
send your questions ahead of time and we
may or may not actually get to them yes
so late Jackson on Facebook asks could
the Big Bang be the birth of a black
hole and are we all living within a
black hole hmm I almost think it would
be the other way around people have
speculated that the black hole could
Harbor a big bang inside so the black
hole is much bigger on the inside than
it is on the outside it could be as big
of the universe on the inside it's like
doctor who's TARDIS you know you can't
in small little red box but inside is an
enormous lab so you fall into the black
hole and you think you've got a
microsecond before you hit the
singularity but your quantum bits get
blown out into a Big Bang so the second
part of that question web blasts says
are we all living within a black hole we
could be like this could be them when we
look back at the Big Bang we might be
looking back at the singularity inside a
black hole in that sense it's not really
inside but in that sense yeah although
most people don't really
take that speculation very seriously
it's it's a it's intriguing to
contemplate I always find myself kind of
going back to that suggestion no matter
how many times people tell me why it's
faulty or what the problems are there's
something appealing about that whether
there's something interesting about the
singularity being in every direction
right so the Big Bang is everywhere you
look right so in that sense it is not
unlike a black hole
yeah the singularity of the Big Bang and
the singularity of a black hole are so
similar that people have just kind of
tried to artificially sew them together
like a quilt and see if it matches on
that same note Dale Chestnut rose on
Facebook says if sounds needs air to
pass through did the Big Bang actually
make a noise how well we're going to
talk about this in a gravitational wave
a home in a sense the Big Bang probably
did make a bang in the sense that it
rang the drum of space-time where you
know you imagine three-dimensional drum
of space-time is ringing in response to
this kind of chaotic event so in that
sense it might have yeah made in a sense
of noise that if we could record the
shape of the ringing drum we would
interpret a sound okay even in the
absence of air what else it changes its
shape slightly and that changes the
gravitational waves that it's mitting
and also around the black hole via the
accretion disk can support sound waves
can't it so this disk that you were
describing of all this material falling
in around the black hole and flattening
it out it can have a sound wave through
that material as long as you as long as
you think of sound waves not as being
something we can hear with our eardrum
but as being waves mediated by some kind
of medium like gas and dye based on like
a Brooklyn DJ okay that's just yeah just
like it's just not what's your hand or
something you can appreciate through
your ears but it kernels are just about
just the feel of the space time you know
anyway here's my disc important question
also coming from next spinel on Facebook
and I don't know which of you two is
going to be the best to answer this can
we send Hillary and Trump to a black
hole
they might annihilate each other
Abdullah got their way you use the
interesting thing about black holes no
matter how you feed them they all look
the same
so you can take a black hole and you can
fill it full of Hello Kitty dolls
you can put old rusty refrigerators in
it you could throw Donald Trump into it
you could throw Hillary Clinton into it
and after it's done settling down you
would have no idea what went into it
this is kind of deep there is no way to
tell the difference between a black hole
made by crushing Donald Trump to a point
and that made by crushing Hillary
Clinton to a point politician Matt Damon
unless all politicians and say this is
the Massachusetts would vote for one and
out the other
that's the only way you can tell so do
we have a last cosmic query in our final
few seconds uh last minute at least here
on earth let me see oh you take one from
the International Space Station to last
longer this is a is there a correlation
between the law of conservation of
energy and the fact that time stops at
the speed of light does this have to do
with light having no mass because it is
pure energy so it's Jacob Seymour
Facebook um read that again yeah okay so
I'm going to try this anything that has
no mass will travel at the speed of
light anything so we think that there
might be subatomic particles that like
neutrinos some neutrinos which might
also have no mass and they would have to
travel also at the speed of light and
and their energy can be converted to MC
squared equals MC squared energy but it
is a pure energy of kinetic energy one
way to think of a equals MC squared
which I've struck upon lately which I
really like is to think of it as your
kinetic energy through time the amount
of energy you transport by your motion
through time so if we were to draw those
space-time diagrams when you're running
on your Google Maps you know you have
some energy as you move through New York
City but you haven't plotted your energy
as you move through time and that's
equals mc-squared energy and on that
note unfortunately we have to take a
quick break but we'll be right back with
star talk all-stars so we can answer
some more of your cosmic queries with
Shep dolmen and Matt kirshen stick
around
back to Startalk all-stars where the
topic of the day is black holes how they
work and how we hope to take a picture
of our first black hole I can't think of
two better people to talk to this topic
than Shep Dolman and astrophysicist and
leader of event horizon telescope
project and the very funny Matt kirshen
who also hosts probably science probably
not science just probably fine specimen
it's been probably not in that what you
don't like by the front I'm Jan 11 your
all-star host for today and I want to
pick up with Shep on the event horizon
telescope because this is still a
project under development you're talking
about we will observe we hope to observe
and there these two objects so first of
all when do you expect to start making
these first pictures of the black hole
at the center of our galaxy and why are
you going to do this good questions so
we started off on the event horizon
telescope project by linking three radio
telescopes around the world together in
Hawaii in Arizona and California and the
first thing we realized was that the
supermassive black hole in the center of
our galaxy Sagittarius a star had a size
that was predicted by this shadow
feature so 100 years ago Einstein came
up with this idea that a black hole
would cast a shadow and we saw exactly
that size and that really got us excited
right because with only three telescopes
all we can do is tell the size of the
black hole now we want to build
instrumentation and put it all the other
telescopes that we can around the world
to fill in this earth sized telescope
and then we can make an image because
the whole reason for doing this is to
look at the size and shape of that
shadow predicted again by Einstein to
test whether Einstein's theories break
down at the edge of a black hole and
also to study the dynamics of matter
around the black hole now we really be
looking all the way at the event horizon
I mean after all light can orbit a black
hole but you know to actually get all
the way to the shadow are you really
seeing the event horizon are you seeing
a little bit further out you see we wind
up seeing a little bit further out
there's something called the last photon
orbit
and light as fast as it goes also is
constrained orbit around the black hole
that's how deform the space-time is it's
a crazy crazy place you can stand with a
flashlight and look at the back of your
head or you could illuminate the back of
your head right and then it was found in
front of you if you're having a bad hair
day you would know it immediately
because that's what you're worried about
when you're you know right outside a
black hole yeah wouldn't your hair
automatically become bad just because
it's kind of being sucked into it how
much means you would see how bad it was
you think your hair feels gravity more
strongly there has to here that's this
we get it because your hair right I try
to be left behind would it kind of be
more frizzy or to be more like high
volume like what kind of shampoo would
you need to here might be special black
hole products I think we've just started
somebody right now is scratching out a
memo and the pharmaceutical company is
something else were wanting to be
outside a word about reciting more ways
to oppress women that's what having your
limbs would you like which cellulite be
changed near black hole how we met your
fire we're going to endorse the haircut
hair care products but I'm not going to
touch that one
so you are making your first
observations when right so from these
three telescopes needs humble beginnings
a global international consortium has
formed and we are now instrumenting
telescopes around the world so in Chile
even the South Pole in France and Spain
and so forth in addition to the ones we
already have and the new observations
are occurring in the spring of 2017
under a year from now that's we light up
most of the array that'll be our first
shot at taking the first image of a
black do you think that's going to be a
successful shot of course I do
getting up every morning it will a lot
of times unity requirements take decades
and the first shots not expected to be
successful and you thinking oh 10 years
down the line will refine enough to
really nail it but you think as early as
spring you're going to have an actual
picture well we are eternal optimist and
even even experiments that are long
shots are always assumed to perhaps give
a good result if not light the way to
future innovations that make inevitable
success you know
reality so we are really focused on
success in spring of 2017 on the same
time nature is nature we have no idea
we're going to see H it doesn't always
comply it does not always comply and we
may fall flat on our face but the idea
is that we get up and we do is this a
done deal the consortium the
international collaboration is on board
and this is definitely going to happen
absolutely so we have time on some of
the biggest apertures some of the
biggest telescopes around the world and
we have these systems that are going to
freeze the light at all of these
telescopes at unprecedented rates I'm
really for you so I'm learning for you
is they're everywhere when you're
setting up these huge telescopes you'll
see something you didn't plan to see
like like like Matt waving yeah
like a neighbor just like making this
but like I guess I'm gonna have to
report this now a quarter on the moon is
like a freckle on the neighbors yeah
yeah yeah so so the yeah we could this
could be like a Milky Way CSI episode or
something like that like murder at the
galactic center well so let me just say
that we think we know we're going to see
but nobody would be happier than most of
the people in the consortium if we saw
something unexpected that would be
hugely interesting and the way I like to
put it is that we will will perhaps be
able to test Einstein's theory but it's
never wise dab it against Einstein but
if we see something crazy if the size of
the shadow is not what Einstein would
have predicted given the mass of that
black hole we will be really scratching
our heads thinking about alternative
forms of gravity we're thinking about
objects even more exotic than a black
hole so would that mean that the whole
theory of general relativity is wrong
and needs to be supplanted well we know
Janna that gr cannot be complete right
because at the center of the black hole
where everything is crushed to a point
of singularity gr has to come into a
chord with quantum mechanics and nobody
not even Einstein ever found a way to do
that so we know gr is complete there
just question is how close do we have to
get to the singularity before it becomes
evident right could be at the event
horizon there could be manifestations of
this deep mystery at the event horizon
that
the event horizon telescope could no
image so there you know you mentioned
quantum phenomenon the Hawking radiation
which happens at the event horizon so
quantum fluctuation in empty space gets
stolen by the black hole and the other
particle radiates and to an observer far
away it looks like the black hole is
actually emitting radiation is that
something you think you could probe with
this telescope we can't see the Hawking
radiation itself because that's going to
be higher energy particles we know that
something strange is happening at the
event horizon right there's this thing
called the information paradox right so
if you throw an encyclopedia into the
black hole what happens the information
in that encyclopedia it's uh I know this
one it's planted by Wikipedia that
everyone now uses and you free up a
bookshelf the conditions for photos and
that kind of thing it's a real
time-saver
you know these black holes but so it
turns out that that information has to
go somewhere
either the Hawking radiation has to
encode it as it evaporates or it gets
frozen onto the surface a lot of
different theories and in some of those
the quantum states inside the black hole
may be in communication with the
exterior of the black hole in that case
you could wind up with different orbits
of photons around the black hole and the
shadow would look different now hmm
exactly how different it might look but
there are ways to think about it from
that framework no it's also possible
that we just couldn't see any effect but
there's still something going on it's
just too difficult to imprint it in such
a macroscopic object yeah I make it
sound easy it's it's you know Colma what
we're doing you make it look easy
that's we go done I'm proud of you okay
people like a home one to build their
own one of your telescopes will hash
they go back they should not because we
don't want any competition don't do this
at home folks it's quite difficult and I
would say that the only way that we're
able to think about doing it is because
we have a global team of exceptionally
talented collaborators that all make it
happen so sometimes you have to kind of
sublimate your own ego right to be part
of this bigger team it's not the lone
pioneer it's really a global effort in
those
it's a real privilege to work with all
these people yeah we're we're excited
too for spring spring 2017 spring 20 hey
stay tuned people we hope the show airs
before then of t-shirts bye then ah I
think it's time for the cosmic queries
lightning round I think I'm supposed to
do miss now you know why Josh I'm not
very good at taking injections and think
that's what I'm supposed to do what do
we got Matt alright from Sean res mucin
who's a patreon patron and I think
you've sort of touched on this already
hi dr. Levin why is it the general
relativity the theory of the large and
quantum mechanics the theory of the
small cannot be reconciled as one theory
of everything if I'm not mistaken dr.
Tyson described general relativity as
being a mathematical shortcuts on a
larger scale because these to be unified
for the new discovery of gravitational
waves or say a graviton thanks for the
show that's unlike Cass unlikely couple
notes nation play like really want to
notice hope you got the accent right
well this is this is a really important
question I mean this is what all
theoretical physicists pine for is a
resolution of the theory of gravity with
the fear of quantum mechanics so the
large theory of the universe on a large
scale on the theory of the universe on
the small scale they're very hard to put
together even if I went through kind of
a standard program this is what I always
do when I try to quantize a model of the
universe it doesn't really work with
gravity because gravity is so nonlinear
right this is not you know the the
effects feed back onto themselves and
these very complex mathematical ways
that we don't know how to control so
literally we just don't know how to
write it down it doesn't mean it doesn't
exist in reality but we just don't know
how to mathematically write it down are
our tools fail us and so many people
have tried just to find better tools but
it might be the case that they're
actually not reconcilable in nature that
gravity in some sense isn't a
fundamental force so you know when I say
the temperature in this room is you know
it's warm in this room temperature isn't
an actual quantity that belongs to
anything it's the collective behavior of
group motions of small things gravity
might be like that it might be the
collective behavior of quantum
entanglement and phenomena like that and
that when we look small enough we
realize
gravity is not really a thing at all
it's something an illusion that only
emerges on large scales I mean that's
just really interesting we love not
knowing the answers right that's why we
have jobs that's why we have something
to do we build telescope yeah all right
trying to see what on Facebook
Travis Eva on Facebook says how the
black holes affect time presumably there
are sharp gravitational gradients in and
around the black hole if so how do these
affect the resulting temporal
distribution of matter thank you
well it's very interesting so well you
mentioned interstellar before so
interstellar interstellar they had this
moment when people went close to the
black hole and you know every hour they
spent down there was twenty years
outside that's a real thing right so
time really does slow down close to the
black hole and they spend time down
there and they came back and everybody
was twenty years older so the there is a
dark time gradients near a black hole
and they do affect the dynamics and when
we think about matter and light orbiting
the black hole we have to take those
into account I'm human
which I go more rapidly rather learning
relation Ellie on Facebook says half of
these questions relative elementary but
how much of our understanding of black
holes relies on our understanding
quantum physics are there mind you
values that influence the structure
black holes that we have identified I
mean in some sense astrophysically not
at all yeah I mean the black holes are
typically classical kind of objects when
you look at them from the outside so
unless we saw Hawking radiation we
wouldn't really be able to see those
quantum fluctuations but there's a whole
community of mathematicians that are at
their desks with pen and paper who are
studying only the quantum aspects only
we'll find them in different buildings
on a university campus all right I
insist Ozzie realest gray name on
facebook says how useful with
space-based radio telescopes be for
taking blackhole pictures Oh they'd be
fantastic so it turns out that one of
the big problems we have is the Earth's
atmosphere it's the water vapor in the
atmosphere that's similar to what makes
stars twinkle for optical telescopes
that limits the event horizon telescope
so if we could take a telescope put it
in orbit they may have a telescope as
big as the the orbital size of that
how big is a radio telescope epoch
across well the largest one that was a
single
we use about 50 meters across 150 feet
across and then we have one in Chile
that it'd be hard to get up in space
alright Mike Snider's on Facebook says
if two black holes one being a bit
stronger than the other words a meet
would they in theory cancel each other
out they would just get bigger and I
mean it just happened
LIGO made that first detection and it's
a that's hateful an amazing result first
time in history we've seen two black
holes collide and what happens is they
make a bigger black hole and some of the
mass though is released as gravitational
wave energy thank you for the great
questions in the lightning round but
sadly we're at the end of our time today
it's been a great day here at Startalk
all stars once again thanks to Shep if
you want to hear more about event
horizon telescope go to event horizon
telescope org and follow Matt on Twitter
at Matt kirshen who is co-host of
probably science podcast which is
especially funny when I'm on it
and I'm Janna Levin thanks for listening
see you around the multiverse this is
Startalk
you
[Music]